let's now go back to our senior
political analyst Maran bashara Maran
Yaya Sina is a man that Netanyahu has
said he will not end this war until he
is dead but it sounds like previous
assassination attempts haven't gone
particularly well and even if they did
go well socalled go well and they did
Kill and assassinate a number of leaders
what we've seen from Hamas over the
past 30 years at least since the the
early
1990s is that every time they get rid of
one Hamas leader a more hardcore Hamas
leader shows up in their place and we've
seen so many uh assassinations of first
and second tier Hamas leaders over the
years notably in the
1990s and I
remember uh doing a a chronology of the
of the assassinations of Hamas leaders
and what you had every time is that
Israel assassinates Hamas leader and
then there's retaliation and response
Israelis die and then another
retaliation happens against Hamas
leaders and Hamas keep producing these
leaders especially the field leaders
like there's no tomorrow I've seen one
of those uh studies that says a lot of
the people and actually there are
declarations recently a lot of the
people who are now serving as a
hardcore uh part of the Hamas striking
force in Gaza today are the Orphans of
people killed by by Israel so the the
assassination uh policy of Israel has
always been more in terms of Revenge and
More in terms of uh public policy to
convince the Israeli public they are
doing something about something but in
in fact strategically speaking it has
always always backfired either in terms
of major retaliations against Israelis
or in terms another uh generation of
more hardcore Hamas leaders showing up
sinir is one example I mean sinir has
spent 22 years in Israeli prison and uh
clearly the assassination uh
assassination The Killing in that in
that sense of his family members
including his children certainly led to
his own radicalization the same thing
with Abu ABA the the field commander
again the assassination of his family
members or the killing of his and in
that sense it wasn't collateral damage
they tried to get Abu Abida but they got
his children they tried to get War but
they got the children so I think in
general assassination policy over the
past 30 years have only backfired have
not led to anything good and have only
led to more and more Hamas retaliations
and the emergence of new generation of
Hardcore leaders see this the thing
about it right anasia is that Israel
continues to do to take on the same
policy again and again and it fails
again and again but yet it continues to
repeat it it's really big is the
question well you were just saying a few
minutes ago that Israel has potentially
misjudged hamas's capabilities well
their military capabilities as these
these Street battles continue what do
you make of of how much how much ground
they've taken so far how how is their
offensive actually going given that it
seems to have stalled
somewhat look in the end of the day they
have the power they have the fire power
and they have apparently uh you know you
know unending support by the United
States in terms of ammunitions and the
likes so I think sooner or later they
will flatten Gaza if need be and they
will get to the Hamas and already they
are so worried and scared of getting
into the tunnels they are destroying the
tunnels yeah and just open parenthesis
here and say they're probably killing a
lot of hostages a lot of captives Israel
today clearly has declared its Hannibal
Doctrine so-called Unwritten Hannibal
doctr
and clearly are sacrificing the captives
in the hands of Hamas because they want
to launch and continue with this war the
land war in Gaza according to recent
reports like in the Wall Street Journal
today they say based on Israeli
assessments that much of
hamas's uh core force remains intact
which is kind of unbelievable when you
consider something like 11,000 civilian
deaths 35 days in tens of thousands of
Civilian casualties and according to
Israeli sources in the W Journal today
that still much of hamas's core force
remains intact but the Israelis are
going to continue and they do as I said
have the Firepower and they did if you
remember recruit or recall 300,000
soldiers so the problem is not so much
of whether they will end up having a
mission accomplished in the immediate
run because we've seen other mission
accomplished right 20 years ago in Iraq
and we saw what happened after that so
they might be able to destroy it more
and more and flatten Gaza as they
continuously say which is a very
inhumane you know concept as it were but
uh they are persistent and they are they
got stuck in this they are lost in this
because of their false assumptions
because of their also false political
assumptions that they could just lock in
Gaza and throw the key and go to have
tourism in Dubai and Abu Dhabi that this
will all be fine well apparently it
can't all be fine and it's not all Rosy
because you decided to be Rosy and this
just final note on this is contrast so
much because this is the only image that
that just sort of you know struck me so
much is only a few weeks ago in
September late September prime minister
prime minister netan was making this Bo
ful speech at the United Nations showing
us map of this flowery Strawberry Fields
in the Middle East centered around
Israel the Magnificent democracy one and
only and
suddenly the strawberry fields are
turning into Killing Fields in Gaza
where Israel is basically taking its
revenge because of its utter foolishness
and stupidity thinking politically
speaking speaking that it could simply
dismiss the Palestinians that it could
make the Palestinians invisible and only
Bridge with some rich Arab countries and
forget about the question of occupation
without resolving the question of
occupation it's not going to get
anywhere well we're listening to the
consequences of all of those assumptions
right now that ongoing gunfire going
literally as we speak in Gaza and a very
dark Gaza that remains Under Siege maam
bashara thank you for joining me again
thank you J